- Go talk to 90-year-olds.
They regret.
They talk about regret.
"I wish" is the opening line.
Hey, man, tell me about your life.
Literally, I wish.
One by one at the airport,
at airport, park or park,
event or event, bar or bar,
every one of them,
all of them started with I wish.
Al of them.
I wish.
They grew up in a generation
that did not have the Internet.
It was not practical to
do all the amazing things
we can be doing.
They all wished.
They wished they worked harder.
They wish they spent more
time with their family.
They wish they didn't listen to their mom
and did what they wanted to do.
- I flew down without
my mom even knowing it.
- [Voiceover] He flew in just for this.
- My mom didn't want to let me go.
Last day, I keep on
pushing, keep on pushing,
keep on pushing.
She lets me go.
Now I'm here.
- They wished, they wished, they wished.
The biggest poison in us is regret.
It's poison.
And I push so hard, so hard,
and will, through my vehicle,
which isn't meditation,
which isn't health and wellness,
which isn't nonprofit.
My vehicle's business.
I can't help it.
It's what I love.
I love building businesses.
I love competing with you.
I want to beat you.
I love that game.
But through that vehicle,
I will always push
a lack of regret and awareness
to how good it really is.
You're more than welcome to tell me about
how bad it is or why you
can't because, for what.
But it's just not true.
Because if anybody ever did it,
then you can, too.